the left launches a crusade to murder
innocent babies in Georgia while
simultaneously doing its best to
overturn the death penalty for rapists
and murderers we will examine the left
inverted judgment and why good judges
matter then a new study shows that
assault weapon bans do not reduce
homicide
finally Dorothy Parker describes all the
ways to kill yourself on this macabre
way to kick off National Poetry Month
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
today's show is all about death
beginning to end it's all about death
because there was a very important
decision that just came down from the
Supreme Court
thanks to Justice Gorsuch and I guess
thanks to justice Cavanaugh because this
was a 5-4 decision on the death penalty
and Cavanaugh was the one where who
replaced Anthony Kennedy he was that
swing vote and he sided with the
Conservatives this is very important and
it's funny I say sided with the
Conservatives because a lot of people
who were conservative or libertarian or
in the conservative movement opposed the
death penalty they hate the death
penalty there they're very wrong about
this and we'll examine why judge Gorsuch
was the one who gave this opinion the
case was buck Lou the presseth the
director of the Missouri Department of
Corrections at al the case was all about
cruel and unusual punishment the case
was all about evolving standards of
decency the case was basically about
whether we can outlaw the death penalty
by making up imaginary things in the
Constitution that's that's really what
it's about whether you like the death
penalty or you don't like the death
penalty what this case is really about
is whether a bunch of robed justices are
benevolent betters or self-appointed
elites can outlaw the death penalty
simply because they imagined something
in the Constitution that isn't there
we'll get to the specifics of this in
just a second but first let us make a
little money honey with candid CO oh yes
listen you know I'm not some giant
Adonis of a man you know I'm not the
most athletically built fella I have a
couple things going for me one of them
my nice shiny teeth a candid ko is
helping people gain confidence through
accessible and affordable orthodontic
care when I was a wee little lad braces
were extremely expensive they were
hideous they were ugly you weren't able
to kiss a girl ever when you had them
because they just didn't look good
candidate ko makes custom clear aligners
that are sent directly to your home you
know in the old days braces were
SuperDuper expensive and what candidate
ko has makes it easier makes it not only
nicer to wear these aligners and fix
your teeth and have a nice smile but
makes it much much
cheaper the first step is to purchase
your starter kit it'll be sent to your
home so you can take impressions of your
teeth that kit retails for ninety five
bucks and orthodontist licensed in your
state reviews your specific case and
creates a 3d preview of what your
treatment and final result will look
like that you can talk to a real person
at any time if you have questions
candids treatment takes an average of
six months it will save you literally
thousands of dollars compared to the
other guys have nice teeth the first
impression is a lasting one this is such
an easy way to have more confidence to
have better interactions in business and
most importantly in your personal life
wink wink
you are one step away from getting
straighter whiter teeth take advantage
of candidates risk-free starter-kit
guarantee plus when you use my dedicated
link candid code comm / cough fa ce o--
v fe fe you'll save 50% on your modeling
kit candid code comm / co with fa ce o--
v FD fe to get 50% off the price of your
modeling kit candid cocom / cove fa what
was this Supreme Court decision about
buck Liu versus pressive director of the
Missouri Department of Corrections this
guy buck Liu he's a convicted murderer
convicted rapist he's on death row he
has blood filled tumors on his neck and
I told you this show was going to be
really tough it's a little grotesque a
little tough to listen to but very
important decision that came in he's got
all these blood filled tumors and what
his lawyers are arguing is because of
this medical condition it could make
lethal injection painful now I know what
you're thinking the guy is going to be
dead in 30 seconds what if he has a
little pain what's the big deal
the question in this case that
ostensibly the judges were looking at is
whether the possibility of this guy
having a painful execution makes the
execution itself cruel and unusual
punishment and therefore
unconstitutional and just ask or search
and Cavanaugh and all the Conservatives
came out and said of course this does
not because you have a tumor on your
neck this does not mean that the state
can't execute you this does not mean
that the death penalty is cruel unusual
punishment the Constitution does not in
or you a painless execution that's one
of the main takeaways from this decision
by the way it was a total cheap trick
total BS this guy buck Lu had faced the
death penalty for eighteen years he was
waiting on death row and then 12 days
before he was scheduled to be executed
all of a sudden he said oh no I've got
this medical condition and we have to
file Appeals so they filed Appeals this
led to five years of litigation the
appeals ran out last year so he was
finally going to be killed there's a
death row for 18 years then another five
years of litigation you look at 23 years
down the line and just as he is about to
be killed the justices halted the
execution when Kath Kennedy sided with
the Liberals so some of the fears with
Kavanagh being appointed to fill
Kennedy's spot is Kennedy sort of liked
him he clerked for Kennedy Kennedy sort
of picked him and there's this fear that
Cavanaugh is going to side with the
Liberals but on this case on this exact
case you saw Cavanaugh siding with the
Conservatives while his predecessor
Kennedy had sided with the Liberals you
are seeing a change in the shift of
power on the court so thank goodness for
Cavanaugh
thank goodness for you know more such
thank goodness for the election of
Donald Trump because you wouldn't have
had any of those things that Hillary
Clinton won so to the actual meat of the
case I guess the question is why do we
need to kill this guy because we're only
arguing over these points of the
Constitution we seem to forget that
there is a criminal here who has
committed serious crimes crimes serious
enough to merit execution in an age
where we don't like killing people very
much this is what a Gorsuch wrote the
people of Missouri these surviving
victims of mr. buck Lou's crimes and
others like them deserve better under
our Constitution the question of capital
punishment belongs to the people and
their representatives not the courts to
resolve now listen to this Adam Smith
used to say he wrote down famously mercy
to the guilty is cruelty to the innocent
and we think all we think about is this
poor or murderous rapist buck Lou who's
got some tumor on his neck and in my
hurt if when he gets lethal injection
that's what we think about we don't
think about the victims of his crimes
which we'll get to in a second most
importantly of all the people that we
always forget about are the citizens the
people of Missouri that listen to how
war such begins this the people of
Missouri
dot-dot-dot deserve better
why why he didn't murder the people of
Missouri not more than a couple of them
he didn't he didn't attack the people of
Missouri he did because crime is an
assault on the country on the community
on justice and therefore the civil
authority has to enforce justice has to
bring us justice because it affects all
of us this is the point of criminal
justice that we always forget we
remember the criminal part we remember
rehabilitation we remember deterrent we
forget about the justice part of it and
this is important and this affects all
of us and we all demand it then of
course Gorsuch gets to the point here
the question of capital punishment
belongs to the people and their
representatives not the courts to
resolve okay obviously at the time of
the ratification of the Constitution
nobody thought that the death penalty
was cruel and unusual punishment the
death penalty was basically the
definition of a felony there was the
death penalty everywhere when the
Constitution was adopted nobody thought
that was cruel and unusual punishment
now today some people think it's cruel
and unusual to kill criminals for
committing crimes it's becoming
increasingly unusual because these
courts and these judges have taken away
the power of the people to decide this
but let's say we don't like the death
penalty anymore society's gone soft we
don't want to kill criminals anymore
what whatever the reason say you don't
trust the state to carry it out you
think there's too much corruption okay
there are a lot of arguments against the
death penalty if you don't like the
death penalty
then convince your fellow citizens and
pass a law outlawing the death penalty
you can do that that's what a
self-governing people is allowed to do
what you shouldn't do is have
attorneys general or DA's or governor's
or presidents or judges just waving
their hand and saying Oh pish-posh
forget about the law we don't need the
law who cares what the people want I
know in my infinite wisdom I know better
than everybody else I know better than
all the citizens of this country the
citizens of this state the framers of
the Constitution I know better than
everybody and so I'm just going to
pretend that the death penalty is
unconstitutional it's not
unconstitutional
it's very constitutional to kill
criminals but if you don't like it fine
convince your fellow citizens and pass a
law however remember that these guys are
pretty bad hombres remember that these
victims deserve justice remember that a
civilized society deserves justice for
the victims on behalf of the victims on
behalf of justice generally and for the
perpetrators this guy buck Liu now 20
years ago 23 years ago I guess went on a
rampage in 1996 after his girlfriend
tried to break up with him we were the
feminists on this where is the me2
movement this guy goes on a violent
rampage as his girlfriend tries to break
up with him she flees to a neighbor's
house he goes over there and shoots and
kills the neighbor he then beats this
woman with his gun and rapes her then
the police come and he gets into a
shootout with the police finally
thankfully he's arrested he's sent to
jail he escapes from jail and then he
goes and attacks the girlfriend's mother
with a hammer this guy needs to be put
down he needs to be taken out back and
put down like Old Yeller for for all
reasons for all three reasons that we
have capital punishment and criminal
justice as a deterrent and we would have
a much better deterrent effect if we had
taken this guy out back and put him down
like Old Yeller in 1997 right after it
happened not twenty three years later we
have to do this for the retributive
effect because this demands justice
justice demands to be satisfied and even
as a matter of rehabilitation I don't
think any amount of therapy is going to
turn this guy around I don't
going into a therapy session and hugging
each other and saying oh hey let's talk
about our feelings Oh daddy didn't go to
your baseball game when you were a kid
oh okay they're there now you're
reformed I don't think so
the only chance this guy has a
rehabilitation is to stare down the
gallows and say well I'm about to meet
my maker in an hour I I had better start
taking these things seriously and I
better throw myself on the ground and
ask for forgiveness that's the only
that's the closest to rehabilitation
this guy's ever gonna get so what's the
bottom line from this case we're talking
about cruel and unusual punishment we're
talking about the eighth amendment to
the Constitution in the Bill of Rights
and this is what Gorsuch writes the 8th
amendment has never been understood to
guarantee a condemned inmate a painless
death that's a luxury not guaranteed to
many people including most victims of
capital crimes this is a great point by
the way for the vast majority of people
on earth for all of human history
no one could can expect a painless death
but we all sort of hope we think you
know when my day finally comes I hope
that I can go out in my sleep
or you know smoking a cigar on a beach
somewhere it's you you you say this oh
gosh I just like a painless death
because for the vast majority of human
history we've had very painful deaths
now he makes that point about everybody
then he makes the point of the victims
of capital crimes because buck Lou's
girlfriend didn't have a pain-free
experience with him his his girlfriend's
mother didn't have a pain-free
experience that neighbor just in the
very moment of that incident didn't meet
a pain-free death and Buck Lou can't
expect to me to pain-free death either
now Neil Gorsuch goes on to clarify what
he means does this mean that we should
torture the guy does this mean that we
should give him an intentionally painful
death no of course not courses rights
what the Eighth Amendment does guarantee
is a method of execution
that's not cruel and unusual and ever
since the founding people have
understood that the only way to tell if
a method is cruel is to compare it with
other known and of a
alternatives to see if the state is
inflicting substantially more pain than
necessary to carry out its lawful
sentence so we're not we don't want
cruel and unusual punishments it goes in
the opinion here they talk about other
punishments that at the time of the
ratification of the Constitution were
done away with drawing and quartering
people disemboweling them those sort of
things would be cruel and unusual they
were understood to be cruel and unusual
at the time and so even as the
Constitution was adopted
you couldn't inflict that sort of
capital punishment on somebody but how
about today this is what the question
that the courts liberals bring up I mean
why are we having this discussion it is
so obvious that that capital punishment
is not unconstitutional and yet a lot of
people are pretending that it is why
because of this one man Chief Justice
Earl Warren in 1958 coins the term
evolving standards of decency he did it
in this case drop versus Dulles evolving
standards of decency this is a very
funny statement because we like to
flatter ourselves we moderns we people
living in 2019 I said gosh we're just
such a decent people we're just so good
we would never do barbaric things like
kill murderers and rapists for their
heinous crimes we would never do awful
indecent things like enforce justice and
bring about justice for the victims of
violent crimes and for the society at
large oh that would be so indecent oh
hey let's go kill a million babies a
year hold on I'm sorry I'm just
I'll be right there I'm gonna go kill a
million babies a year I'm gonna go
boycott Georgia because they don't want
to kill a million babies a year but hold
on one side just have to finish my
lecture on decency but I'll be right
there
and then we can go kill all of those
babies I'm sorry where was I oh yes I
was talking about our evolving standards
of decency and how much more decent we
are today than those awful people in the
past who enforced capital punishment for
violent criminals and also didn't kill a
meal
in babies a year decency so Gorsuch
basically goes right at the jugular of
this stupid idea from Earl Warren and he
says quote the Constitution allows
capital punishment in fact death was
quote the standard penalty for all
serious crimes at the time of the
founding it was the definition of a
serious crime
you hang he goes on nor did the later
edition of the Eighth Amendment outlaw
the practice on the contrary the Fifth
Amendment added to the Constitution at
the same time as the Eighth expressly
contemplates that a defendant may be
tried for a capital crime and deprived
of life as a penalty so long as proper
procedures are followed it is manifestly
clear that the Constitution permits the
state to deprive criminals of life for
serious crimes this is an argument also
for originalism because especially on
this case because conservatives are
divided about this Pope Benedict said
this when when he was still Pope which
is that there can be legitimate
disagreement among Catholics as to the
question of the death penalty he's
recognizing Catholics are very split on
the question of the death penalty this
new pope wants to pretend that there
can't be a legitimate disagreement but
there can be and the same is true for
the conservative movement I totally get
the arguments against the death penalty
I don't think they're ultimately
convincing I don't even think they're
really that good but there are
legitimate arguments I think there can
be totally legitimate disagreement among
conservatives about the death penalty
however there cannot be a legitimate
disagreement over the constitutionality
of the death penalty the death penalty
is obviously repeatedly manifestly
constitutional and even if you don't
like the death penalty even if you wish
that there were some prohibition of the
death penalty in the Constitution you
still should defend original as
you still should defend what the
Constitution means you still should
defend the constitutionality of the
death penalty why is that because what
is the alternative
even the liberals should defend
originalism even the radicals even the
radical reformers because what is the
alternative I've got to ask
Justice Scalia this when I was still in
college I got to meet him twice before
he died and one of the questions that
was asked was shouldn't this shouldn't
this method of constitutional
interpretation originalism shouldn't
this just be taken in the context of all
the other methods of constitutional
interpretation and he said what other
method at least originalist s-- have a
clear interpretive scheme at least
originalist have a clear interpretive
methodology what's the constitutional
interpretive methodology of Ruth Bader
Ginsburg or Sonia Sotomayor
it's willy-nilly what is the clear
method of constitutional interpretation
of Earl Warren there isn't one it's
whatever little fancies pop into his
head who is to decide evolving standards
of decency Earl Warren I guess just
whatever they want they say you know
those framers obviously allowed for the
death penalty but today I Ruth Bader
Ginsburg don't like it and so I'm gonna
pretend it's unconstitutional okay well
I think I think when the framers wrote
the Constitution I think what they
really meant was that in 2019 Michael
Knowles should get a lifetime supply of
chick-fil-a sandwiches I'm pretty sure
that's what they meant that's just what
I feel because because that would form a
more perfect union for me so I think
they were a We the People in order to
form a more perfect union
obviously my having free chick-fil-a
sandwiches for the rest of my life would
make the Union more perfect definitely
to me so give me my chick-fil-a it's
there look it's just evolving it's just
an evolving understand
I know what you're gonna say there
wasn't chick-fil-a at the time with the
ratification right right
but because of evolving standards of
decency because of evolving standards of
taste and deliciousness
I think it's manifestly clear that in
order to form a more perfect union you
need to give me free chicken sandwiches
for the rest of my life what the
Liberals on the court are saying is not
in any way less ridiculous than the
statement that I just made and and I
really am waiting I know a few liberals
left wingers who would call themselves
textual lists and originalist because
they see that what's good for the goose
is good for the gander they see that
either you accept the meaning of the
Constitution for what it is or you don't
have a Constitution either you accept
what the words mean and then if you
don't like them you amend the
Constitution or if there's more wiggle
room in the law you just pass a law or
you don't have law or you don't have the
Constitution this this reminds me of
that Bible analogy when people say they
start quoting the Bible out of context
Alyssa Milano does this a lot we'll get
to that in a second to defend the
indefensible but when people say well in
the Bible it says this and that's why
and then they go form all these crazy
conclusions from it looking at the Bible
without context without a knowledge of
history and trying to draw a grand
theological conclusions from that is
like looking down a deep dark well and
all you see is your own reflection on
the surface this is why there are thirty
thousand denominations of people who all
have the one true interpretation of the
Bible and they it was finally discovered
in 1967 finally Oh after 2,000 years of
darkness
finally random Joe Schmo has figured out
the true meaning of the okay fine
whatever
the same thing about the Constitution
when you look down at that profound
document with all that profound history
and tradition that it represents and all
of the tradition that's come from it and
you look down it and you take it
completely out of context completely out
of the context of what the
words meant by the people who wrote them
and what they were commonly understood
to mean at the time of ratification you
are just looking down a deep dark well
and all you see is your own reflection
on the surface your own evolving
standards of decency or in this case
indecency excellent decision from Judge
Gorsuch excellent decision from
Cavanaugh and Alito and Roberts and
Thomas all the good conservatives well
done guys really glad we won that last
presidential election so we got those
two judges to make a very good decision
speaking of death there is an evolving
indecency standard from Alyssa Milano
who now is leading the charge in
Hollywood to boycott Georgia why you ask
because Georgia doesn't want to kill as
many babies this has become the crusade
now Alyssa Milano is invoking God in her
quest to kill more babies we will
analyze Alyssa Milano's very suspect
theology then news that the assault
weapons ban doesn't lower homicide then
a poem about suicide to kick off
National Poetry Month but first go to
daily wire.com you have to do it you
have got to do it listen to the headline
today from Think Progress this was after
that decision came down from Judge
Gorsuch Gorsuch just handed down the
most bloodthirsty and cruel death
penalty opinion of the modern era
get your tumblers out you need the
tumbler or the tears will get all over
your computer or your phone or your god
and it will all break apart all your
electronics will fizzle and then you'll
drown so go get the leftist here's
tumblr ten bucks a month $100 for annual
membership you get everybody at the
daily wire you get to ask questions in
the mailbag coming up Thursday so make
sure to get your questions in we'll be
right back with a lot more
Alyssa Milano is invoking God to kill
more babies okay so why is this the
background here is that Georgia is
trying to pass a heartbeat bill this is
the idea that you can't kill babies down
the line now we know that 80 percent of
Americans oppose late-term abortion we
know that two-thirds of Americans who
identify as pro-choice oppose late-term
abortion the vast majority of this
country opposes late term abortion but
Hollywood loves late term abortion and
the Democrat Party loves late term
abortion and the Democrat governor of
Virginia loves abortion after the
child's already been born and the
governor of New York loves abortion
while the child is being born and all of
the Democrat senators love taking away
protections for babies who survived
abortion they've just gone crazy on the
question of abortion so now George is
trying to pass this heartbeat bill to
save some babies and Hollywood is up in
arms because a lot of TV and film is
shot in Georgia this has been going on
for years now Georgia had a lot of tax
incentives for Hollywood to come out
there and so it's brought a lot of the
industry out to Georgia now Hollywood is
threatening to take it all away if they
don't let them keep killing babies and
serving them up to Moloch for dinner so
Alyssa Milano is leading the charge of
course Alyssa Milano the voice of her
liberal generation Alyssa Milano has
somehow become the most articulate
spokesperson on the left it's her in
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez and she's
leading Amy Schumer Judd Apatow Alec
Baldwin all threatening to boycott if
Georgia doesn't keep killing babies also
for those last two guys Judd Apatow and
Alec Baldwin how creepy is it when men
are pro-abortion extremists it is the
creepiest thing it's creepier than beta
or work well I guess he's I guess he's
just an example of that never mind it's
so so creepy it's creepy when women do
it too but it's especially creepy when
men do it this is what they wrote quote
we cannot in good conscience continue to
recommend our industry remain in Georgia
now Hollywood brings a lot of money to
Georgia Hollywood
brings a lot of work to Georgia because
a lot of people now gone to Georgia
worked in the industry working around
the industry working downstream of the
industry so Hollywood is now literally
offering to Georgia a deal with the
devil they're saying whoo hey do you
like all that Mammon that we keep
bringing you hmm do you like how we keep
satisfying all of your lusts and greed
and giving you a lot of money do you
like that okay we'll keep doing that but
you have to keep feeding us all of those
babies of yours you have to keep giving
us all those babies listen here's it's a
really simple tax incentive structure
you just give us a little bit of a tax
incentive and you pour an endless stream
of babies down the gullet of Baal to
satisfy his demonic urges and then we'll
keep bringing you the jobs come on it's
no big deal we hash these out all the
time I'll get my agent from CIA on the
line we'll hash it out you'll give us
all your babies and we'll eat them and
it's all good right okay that is what a
deal with the devil is so it's no
surprise that Alyssa Milano
is now invoking God to justify killing
babies here's what she wrote I love God
I believe in God but I don't believe my
personal beliefs of which we can't
confirm should override scientific facts
and what we can confirm okay as she goes
on to quote John 3:12 but I'll just
obviously try to get past the incoherent
grammar and syntax she says I love God
I believe in God that's interesting I
didn't know that she believed in God I
take her at her word
so she believes in God but I don't
believe my personal beliefs which we
can't confirm should override scientific
facts and what we can confirm so she
doesn't believe in God because what
she's saying is that God is a personal
belief that she can't confirm and it's
not and God is not a fact the existence
of God is not a fact so she's saying the
existence of God is not knowable
she is not claiming that God exists
she's not claiming that the statement
God exists is true which is really
saying is I sort of have this personal
feeling about
I just have the feels you know sometimes
I imagine certain things and I guess one
of them is God but it's the existence of
God is not a fact so I prefer scientific
facts
what scientific facts is she talking
about
we know that unborn babies are babies we
know that they're alive they're not dead
they're not rocks they're living we know
that they're humans they're not giraffes
they're not platypuses they're not
goldfish they're humans so they're
living human babies that's a scientific
fact now taking God out of it for just a
second it's very I don't know what her
personal beliefs really are on God she
hasn't really explained that very much
we do know the personal belief that
she's really pushing here is that it is
morally acceptable to kill babies but
then look at what she just said she said
that personal beliefs that we can't
confirm should not override scientific
facts that we can confirm babies are
babies that's a scientific fact that we
can confirm it is morally acceptable to
kill babies and murder them in the womb
that is a personal belief that we most
certainly cannot confirm even if you
believe that it's true even if you think
it's perfectly fine to kill babies in
the womb at the very least you would
have to admit that is a personal belief
and we can't confirm it you can't
confirm that to me right okay so if it
is the case that we should not allow
personal beliefs that we can't confirm
to override scientific facts that we can
confirm then we most certainly should
not be killing babies in Georgia or
anywhere else for that matter
she actually makes the case for the
opposite of the thing that she thinks
she's making the case for and then she
goes on and quotes John 3:12 if I have
told you earthly things and you do not
believe how can you believe if I tell
you heavenly things
again just a total total self owned just
a total colossal attack on her own
argument here is an earthly thing babies
or babies
that's an earthly thing and you do not
believe that so how can you possibly
believe if you're told heavenly things
really bad argument really weird
obsession really out of line with the
vast majority of Americans who oppose
killing babies in the womb that's
Hollywood for you no wonder people
aren't going to their movies that's so
weird I want doesn't make any sense does
it
no wonder unplanned a pro-life movie one
of the first ever made made on a
shoestring budget cut off from social
media savaged by the mainstream critics
became the number 5 movie in America
over the weekend 94% audience score it's
a huge when you look at it you know
there voxcom is finally admitting they
finally say they went crazy with the
Russia thing it was Matt tabi from
Rolling Stone said in purely
journalistic terms this is an epic
disaster
Sean ihling from Vox said a lot of
people simply did not want to believe
that Trump was a legitimate president
that someone this vulgar and this
dishonest will win the election and I
think that disbelief and the emotional
devastation of his election colored a
lot of our judgments basically taking a
maiya culpa and saying you know we all
wait crazy
gosh wasn't that crazy how for two years
we all convinced ourselves that Donald
Trump the guy we've all known for 40
years tabloid star reality TV store that
that guy was actually a super-secret
double agent spy working for the Kremlin
wow what a crazy self induced psychosis
we've just lived through that's what
we're seeing with abortion we're gonna
look back on this or future generations
are going to look back and say do you
know that the most famous people in the
country people who were in movies and TV
they were totally obsessed
with killing babies and they do you know
they made arguments invoking the name of
God himself to justify killing babies
how on earth did that happen it's a self
induced psychosis and the way you've
know it's a psychosis is it's basically
only believed by these small numbers of
lunatics in Hollywood that they are not
representative of the American people
they're not representative of Democrats
they're not representative of liberals
they're not even representative of
people who support abortion even people
who support abortion two-thirds of them
oppose late term abortion these guys
cheer on abortion up until the babies
being born and some of them thereafter
that is a self induced psychosis and
they're all going to look very foolish
in the coming years they already look
foolish I guess but it's a very
dangerous game to be invoking God on
these things they might have
consequences beyond just public opinion
speaking of death again there was a new
study that came out you know we've been
told by all these same people we need to
ban the ar-15 we need to ban large
capacity magazines we need to bet we
need to do something do something
David hog is going to go on television
and call senators murderers and
terrorists all those kids from Parkland
who decided to try to get famous off of
a tragedy they go on TV if you don't
stop taking money from the NRA if you
don't ban the ar-15 if you don't ban
high-capacity magazines you're AB murder
or you're a terrorist you have blood on
your hands turns out none of that's true
it was a study that came out it's called
the impact of state firearm laws on
homicide and suicide deaths in the USA
1991 to 2016 a panel study this study
looked at four states it looked at ten
different types of gun control it
concluded high-capacity magazine
and assault weapons bans do not lower
homicide rates period boom to ibasta now
I sort of say these things in a with a
little bit of a sarcastic voice or I'll
put them in quotes when I write it
because what is a high-capacity magazine
I think in California these days it's
like if you can have eleven rounds
that's high-capacity what is an assault
weapon assault weapon is a made-up term
there's what's the difference between a
regular hunting rifle that you can think
of and an ar-15 assault weapon
practically basically no difference at
all
a lot but the reason that they use these
terms the reason that activists invented
these terms is because they create a
false image in your mind when you hear
assault weapon you think of an assault
rifle you think of a fully automatic
rifle you think of a machine gun you
think of people going into war pulling
the trigger once and having a spray of
bullets coming you think of Al Capone
with a tommy gun what is an assault
weapon though that's just a gun you pull
the trigger once and one bullet comes
out fully automatic weapons have been
outlawed for a very long time heavily
heavily regulated pull the trigger once
one bullet comes out and the the people
who are pushing gun control laws are so
disingenuous this study is not going to
change their mind it was never about
preventing homicides it was never even
about preventing mass shootings we know
for a fact that many many many more
people are killed every year from
handguns
then from ar-15s and actually any rifle
all put together order of magnitude and
multiples more people killed from
handguns more people are killed from
hammers and baseball bats then are
killed from ar-15s and yet they go after
the ar-15 one is the air 15 is a very
popular rifle and two because they know
they can trick people because it looks
scary it's not really much more lethal
it just looks really scary and they know
the thinking is totally disingenuous all
of a gun grabbing law so this is a good
statistic to have to be able to cite but
it's not going to change anybody's mind
it's not going to
it's it's it's not really going to
change the discourse other than giving
the people who want to protect our
rights and our liberties and our
Constitution a little more ammo so to
speak but it doesn't matter the the
arguments over gun control are not going
to be won on statistics very few
arguments generally are won over
statistics I was just talking about this
last night at Drew University which is I
was giving a talk last night on identity
politics there and at all these schools
the students will come up and ask how
can I make more compelling arguments to
the left and I say stop being an egghead
stop using statistics statistics or a
fine they're all welling good they're
sort of impressive they're also easily
manipulable and especially in the social
sciences so that's fine cite a few
statistics but arguments are not won in
lost on statistics you have to make a
moral argument you have to make a
qualitative argument you have to say the
reason that we need the Second Amendment
is to protect or Liberty the framers of
the Constitution knew this we need to
have the Second Amendment in case the
government ever turns tyrannical and
tries to take away our Second Amendment
democratic governments have turned
tyrannical many many times throughout
the West in recent history happened all
throughout Europe it hasn't happened
here yet good thing one of the reasons
that it very very likely will never
happen here is because we have the right
to keep and bear arms the right to keep
and bear arms is not about hunting it's
not a bad target practice it's about
protecting me and my family and my
friends and my property
that's in a very personal tangible way
in a broader sense it's about protecting
my community it's about protecting my
liberty it's about protecting my way of
life it's about protecting my traditions
it's about protecting our system of
governance in in the United States
that's what it's about oh and also
assault weapon bans don't do anything to
change the homicide rate it's a little
addendum there even if you could make a
good moral argument you lefties you're
also making a completely stupid argument
because the thing that you're proposing
doesn't achieve the thing that you say
will achieve
but it's not in efficiency that is the
cause of the argument being bad it's the
premises themselves it's the arguments
themselves from the left that are bad
and we should discuss them on those
terms do we have time to talk about
Biden's
second accuser oh I really want to talk
about it but I think we're out of time
so instead I will end oh gosh it's so
good though because I have to defend you
Biden again I have to do it I guess
we'll have to do it tomorrow more people
coming out of the woodwork
looks like Bernie Sanders is behind a
lot of these hits and it's just a
totally BS disingenuous attack we'll get
to it tomorrow before we leave today
it's National Poetry Month poetry is
basically dead nobody reads poetry
anymore but conservatives should read
poetry
don't be an egghead make good arguments
could people forget we think of
conservatives in this day and age as
these sterile cold clinical calculating
economists types when Edmund Burke began
what we would call modern conservative
thought he said the age of chivalry has
gone that of Sophos ters economists and
calculators has succeeded it and the
glory of Europe is extinguished forever
Edmund Burke and the Conservatives who
follow in his tradition or knots
officers economists and calculators
actually the people who follow right
after Burke were the romantics Romantic
poets Coleridge those guys and so it's
National Poetry Month the left is sort
of alienated conservatives from poetry
because they've written horrific poetry
for a century so when you think of
poetry you think of some schmuck wearing
a black beret in some club downtown
saying like fish I saw my dad in the
hallway hamburger and they think that
that's a poem you know as as the
literary critic Harold Bloom said slam
poetry is the death of art but good
poetry is a wonderful thing and it
enriches our lives and and it they're
gonna be light poems they're gonna be
funny poems they're gonna be profound
poems they're can be you know poetry is
just a wonderful art form it's too bad
that it died so to begin in keeping with
our theme today I'm I wanted to read a
very mediocre poem but sort of funny
nonetheless by Dorothy Parker called
resume and I will try to try to bring up
some more poems as they occur to me
throughout National Poetry Month rescue
made by Dorothy Parker razors pain you
rivers are damp acids stain you and
drugs cause cramp guns aren't lawful
nooses give gas smells awful you might
as well live that's our show
I'll be back tomorrow see you then in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show the Michael Noel's
show is produced by Robert Sterling
executive producer Jeremy Moore senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis clever and our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
edited by Dani D'Amico audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Jessa
of era production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
today on the Ben Shapiro show is the
Democratic Party ready to break with Joe
Biden and Barack Obama that's today on
the Ben Shapiro show